[Music]
foreign
2023 the Brazilian government declared a
state of emergency over the health of
the indigenous people in horaima
accusing the previous government of
neglect amounting to genocide
indigenous communities throughout
horaima are suffering from malnutrition
tuberculosis starvation and most grave
of all a deadly explosion in malaria
cases
we're trying we are trying uh the most
fast we can but it's not fast enough
[Music]
horima is the northernmost state of
Brazil sharing borders with Venezuela
and Guyana
it's Brazil's least densely populated
state a landscape dominated by dense
jungle Savannah and rivers
around 46 percent of horaima land is
indigenous territory home to among
others the makushi wapishana and
Yanomami people
and it is these people who are at the
Forefront of the malaria crisis in the
region is
a member of the Yanomami community and
president of urihi and the yanamami
district indigenous Health Council
organizations both dedicated to the
protection of his people's rights and
their health
junior is heavily involved in the
emergency response acting as a
go-between and translator between
indigenous people and health workers it
can be harrowing work
foreign
[Music]
since the Declaration of emergency
groups of care workers and scientists
have mobilized against the crisis
they have been able to make some
progress against starvation and
malnutrition but the problem of malaria
is harder to treat
the poor
Works in an advisory role foreign an
organization responsible for the health
care response to the crisis
though her training is in a rather
different area is
Sienna's colleagues have a long and
difficult journey to reach the
indigenous territories traveling by
plane boat and helicopter
is
and once they do get out to the
territories there aren't enough medical
staff to oversee the full term of
medication
as you think don't Focus personalizing
yeah
trading a remote group is a challenge
for health workers but the reality is
that no matter what they do there are
larger problems at play here problems at
the root of the whole crisis
thing is
the current Health crisis is largely
attributed to a recent boom in illegal
mining in indigenous territories
miners bring diseases with them
tuberculosis and malaria
in the mining activity itself creates
the perfect conditions for a malaria
outbreak
miners cut down trees and the Mercury
they use to extract gold poisons the
rivers this means that indigenous people
can no longer hunt or fish and become
malnourished
tension in the region is high with
reports of attacks and rape common
in 1992 the Yanomami territory the
largest indigenous territory in horaima
was given protected status against
mining but the practice has long had a
place in the area's history episode
the move to protect the indigenous
territories in the early 90s followed
the Boom in mining that had serious
consequences for indigenous health
after the law was passed the mines were
closed and the miners removed indigenous
communities were able to begin to
recover
that is until jair bolsonaro was elected
in 2018.
he cut back funding from funai the state
department set up to protect indigenous
people in their land and attempted to
push through a law that would legalize
mining in indigenous lands all the while
making statements that were seen to be
explicitly encouraging mining
foreign
[Music]
illegal mining exploded people flocked
to the territories both from Brazil and
over the borders from Venezuela and
Guyana
forests were cut down riverbeds dug up
and the problem started again
fast forward to today and things have
changed once more the new government is
once again clamping down on illegal
Mining and workers are scrambling to
reverse some of the changes that took
place here during bolsonaro's four years
in power
[Music]
this is
a health center for indigenous people
set up in the aftermath of the 90s
crisis on the outskirts of state capital
Boa Vista
but like so many of the structures in
place to help indigenous people it's
suffering after years of underfunding
the
moments
is microscope
foreign
for many indigenous patients the journey
to get here is long and difficult
patients are often accompanied by their
whole families and will stay for a
number of weeks
some patients with chronic illness are
permanent residents
kazai has the capacity to maintain a
rigorous testing program every resident
at kazai is tested for malaria weekly
and anyone testing positive is
immediately treated
testing is full-time work with health
workers often spending hours pouring
over hundreds of samples at these
microscopes only to start the process
again the next week
but this scale of testing and speed of
treatment simply isn't possible in
remote areas to control malaria in these
places scientists and health workers
need to find an alternative approach
there is one technique that could help
it's called Mass Drug Administration or
MDA
MDA was approved by The Who in 2016 to
be used in isolated areas against
plasmodium falciparum the most deadly
malaria parasite it involves treating
entire communities with anti-malarial
drugs without requiring a positive
malaria test from each individual which
in remote areas is difficult to manage
in horaima it has the potential to save
many lives
scientists and health workers are in
discussion with the Ministry of Health
about how MDA could be put into practice
one of the key voices in this discussion
is
oneron has been working in indigenous
Health since 1987 during the last crisis
foreign
on their own believes that implemented
properly MDA could help turn the tide of
malaria cases in remote areas
questions
but MDA is not without controversy and
the Brazilian authorities are wary of
its risks
is
the health surveillance coordinator at
the State Health Department
she trained as a pharmacist so knows
about the risks of misusing medications
[Music]
foreign
policy makers and health workers like
coneron and Luciana are hopeful that MDA
will play a key role in limiting further
deaths from malaria in the horaiman
Indigenous population
but the challenges posed by this malaria
outbreak don't end in remote areas
since the Crackdown on illegal mining by
the current government more and more
miners are relocating back to cities
like Boa Vista where normally malaria
levels are low
and with this migration comes the risk
of transmission
is
surveillance practices are key to
valdeni's plan to contain the risk is
it's clear that there's a huge range of
challenges but Luciana and valdereni are
still hopeful
internationalized uh
for now without
urgent action more people will die and
if the problem of malaria isn't solved
then it will only get worse
epidemiological approaches Mass Drug
Administration and dynamic testing
regimes can all help limit deaths from
malaria in the short term
there are also other options new malaria
vaccines continue to be approved and are
currently news in several countries in
Africa
but beyond malaria there are other
significant health challenges in the
region
indigenous communities are struggling
with an outbreak of tuberculosis and
malnutrition is still a problem
and even if malaria can be eliminated in
the short term researchers and
healthcare workers like Luciana argue
that systems need to be implemented in
more remote areas which Empower
indigenous communities to recognize
prevent and treat malaria without
needing the help of Outsiders
importance of Venezuela
entrance
for now there is a long way to go
and even following the best scientific
practice this will be an uphill struggle
boys
foreign
[Music]
as well as the monument to mining there
is another statue in Boa Vista near to
The River's Edge
it depicts Portuguese settlers trading
and living peacefully alongside
indigenous people under the eyes of the
indigenous God makunaima
this is not what we see in horima but
Luciana and others like her still choose
to hope for a better future
every day it's getting better let's
let's do the job let's do the job
[Music]
mommy still be
holding this guy
they support the sky they say they say
that they support and they and they
I believe them